liebes tagebuch heute morgen bei henry
ganz aufgeregt weil er so einen hunger
hatte ich glaube tom ist auch aber er
hat ganz brav gewartet
ich habe maxi katzenfutter dose zum
aufmachen gegeben
er ist so stark dann hatte ich eine
lustige idee
ich habe einfach die dose mit dem
katzenfutter in die schale getan
henry hat den witz nicht verstanden und
thomas fand ihn wohl blöd manchmal will
henry von thomas schale essen obwohl er
das gleiche hat danach habe ich von
meinem adventskalender das dritte
türchen aufgemacht
heute war schokolade drin dutt hatte
auch hunger er isst am liebsten salat
gomez wollte wissen was in dem terrarium
drin ist er hat es aber irgendwie nicht
verstanden
das war mein outfit of the day ich liebe
das harry potter t shirt ich verstehe
diesen käppi trend nicht irgendwie mag
ich sie aber irgendwie auch nicht
dann musste ich die wohnung saugen und
ich habe meinen adventskranz ausprobiert
er funktioniert snap chat haben mirella
und ich uns darum gebettelt wer besser
kinderlieder nachsehen kann ich glaub
ich hab gewonnen
dann haben meine katzen gekämpft aber
das wollte dass ich die kamera ausmachen
ich habe mich von ihm verabschiedet und
bin dann in die stadt gefahren
im einkaufszentrum hatten sie einen
riesigen leuchten in tannenbaum
den fand ich schön ich habe kurz
überlegt mir einen tannenbaum zu klauen
habe es aber dann doch gelassen
danach habe ich einen mann gesehen der
sehr lustig war
haha ich mag den weihnachtsmarkt mit
seinen leuchtenden boden
auch wenn sie nur ramsch verkaufen bei
lasch verkaufen sie seife aber ich finde
es riecht zu stark danach und man hält
es kaum aus in der bahn nach hause habe
ich dann kommentare gelesen und
irgendwie mark tom ist keine
wasserflaschen henry macht es nichts aus
zum schluss hat mir henry geholfen eine
nikolaus überraschung einzupacken
ich glaube manchmal hätten sie auch
gerne daumen ende